(quirky sound)
- And Mookie walks into
my room, and she goes,
"I want to sleep here,"
and I'm like, "Oh, ha-ha!"
(hysterical laughter)
(audience laughter)
(techno rock music)
(audience applause)
- Here's the show,
it's very simple,
just a bunch of funny people,
who are all telling
true stories.
You guys might know
him from his podcast
"Occasionally Awesome" that
he does with Nick Youssef.
Ladies and gentlemen, Mr.
Kevin Christy everybody!
Let 'em hear it!
(audience applause)
- So, I'm a dude and I like
sex like sex like dudes do,
but this one time in my life
I had to turn down sex.
One time.
(audience laughter)
'Cause like you,
you look like me,
that's not a thing
we should do. Ever.
(audience laughter)
I...we shouldn't, we shouldn't.
Look, it's hard
for us to get it,
so when they offer we're like,
"Yeah this...it happened!"
So, you know, and
you understand,
we live the same existence.
(audience laughter)
So one time I got a job,
I got an acting job.
Okay I say it was a
job, it was a favor.
A friend of mine asked me
to do a favor, he said,
"Will you be in this
thing?" And I said, "Yes,"
because he is black,
and I do whatever black people
tell me to 100% of the time.
(audience laughter)
'Cause I feel guilty about
slavery like I fucking should.
(audience laughter)
So I said "yes" to
doing this. Now,
when you work as an actor
sometimes, you go out of town,
they put you in a
hotel, it's awesome.
You don't live there,
you didn't pay for it,
so you just rub your
ass all over everything.
You get naked as soon as you
walk in and rub your butt
on everything they made.
You just ruin a
Radisson, it's great.
(audience laughter)
So I'm on my way to the
airport and I text him.
I go, "Hey, what's the name of
the hotel we're staying at?"
And I get a text back that goes,
"No player, you're staying in
a condo with the other actors.
Bring your own sheets."
(audience laughter)
"Bring your own sheets" is
never a good thing to hear
in any circumstance, so I'm
like, I'm already going,
I'm like, "Oh God."
So I get there,
and I'm staying in a condo
with four other people,
all of which are
way younger than me,
and are all drug addicts
who were just going to
bone the living shit
out of each other.
It was like "The Real World,"
but then someone
brought their dad.
(audience laughter)
So like I'm, they're
all in their 20s,
I'm angrily in my 30s,
and every night they all
get completely shit hammered
and bone the crap
out of each other,
it was like a rugby
scrum all the time.
(audience laughter)
It was crazy.
And so where we were, we
were in a place called
Ocean City, Maryland,
which is called--
(audience yells)
You're the first
on to "woo" for it.
(audience laughter)
Okay. To be fair it's
like a summer place,
where there's like a boardwalk,
but this was the winter, okay?
So it was like a fun beach
town with carnival games,
but in the dead of winter.
So there would be
just like a weird guy
trying to sell flip flops
even though it was four
degrees outside. He's like,
"Hey do you want
these flip flops?"
We're like, "No, why..." It's
like selling a snow shovel
here in Los Angeles, it's like
why are you doing this here?
This doesn't make
any fucking sense.
(audience laughter)
So it sucked, and we're
there...I'm there the whole time
with these people,
and every night they
would bone like I said.
Now, I had a side job as
an illustrator at the time.
I had to do some artwork
while I was there,
but I couldn't
paint in my bedroom,
I had to paint in the
kitchen because that's where
the table was. So every night,
I would be there painting,
and there'd be like
two 20 year-olds
fingering each other next to me,
and I'd be like
quietly painting a tree
for like a men's calendar.
"You guys look like
you're having fun,
I'm just working on
this branch over here.
Get off her!"
(audience laughter)
Like you know, it was a lot,
and then there was a
girl in the thing right,
who I don't remember
her real name,
but everybody called her
Mookie for some reason.
She was the hottest Latin
woman I've ever seen
in my whole fucking life.
And if you know anything about
Latin women, they're better.
That's just how the world works.
(audience laughter)
And the thing is, when they're
hot, they're nice about it,
Whereas like white hot
women are just dicks.
(audience laughter)
Like they just think
they're so great,
whereas like Latin women are
hot, you're like "You're hot!"
They're like
"Really, seriously?"
Like it's something they
don't know, it's fantastic,
whereas like when you tell
a white woman she's hot,
she's like "Really?
I know." You're like,
"Oh, this is awful."
(audience laughter)
So Mookie was the hottest,
and she was just...
all the best,
like the greatest things
about like Latin women
were everything she was.
All she talked about was
how she loved dancing,
so everything was like,
"The thing about
me is I'm just like
dancing dancing dancing, ba
ba ba ba ba, living life,"
like that was her
answer to everything.
(audience laughter)
You're just like,
"Hey what do you think
about the Middle East?"
"Dancing dancing dancing,
ba ba ba, living life."
You're like, "This is
awesome, you're awesome."
Now, every night
she would get wasted
and try to hook
up with somebody.
Boys, girls, didn't matter,
she was going to get it.
That's how much she
loved, you understand?
And it was so nice of her,
'cause she was so hot,
she was like, "Everyone
should experience this,
regardless of sex."
And so, every night she
would hook up with somebody.
Now I wasn't engaging in this
because I was at the
time engaged, okay?
And so one night, I'm in my
room quietly reading a book
like a sad white person,
and all of a sudden
I hear footsteps just
coming down the hall,
and then I hear my door
quietly open, and it's Mookie.
And Mookie walks into
my room, and she goes,
"I want to sleep here."
(audience laughter)
Okay.
And at that moment,
instant boner.
(audience laughter)
Like just like a
a rocket launch.
My dick was like, "Seriously?!"
Like it just got so
excited, and she's like,
"I want to sleep here."
And I'm like, "Oh, ha-ha!"
(laughing hysterically)
Just started laughing, and
then it turned into tears,
and I'm like, "Oh
Mookie you can't,
you can't sleep here,
you can't sleep
here, you can't."
And she's like, "No I
want to sleep here."
And I'm like, "You can't,"
she goes, "Why?"
I go, "'Cause
Mookie, I'm engaged,
that's basically
like being married."
And all out of nowhere she goes,
"I'm married to Christos 10
years, I don't love him!"
(audience laughter)
And I'm like, "That's
a lot of info for me."
Who marries a guy named
Christos first of all?
That's a weird ass name.
Did he have a yacht?
If he doesn't that's lame,
'cause if your name is Christos,
you should have a fucking yacht.
(audience laughter)
So then I'm like,
"No I'm sorry about you and
Christos, that's a bummer,
but you still can't sleep here."
And then she goes, "I
want to be warm with you."
(audience laughter)
Which, think about
how good that sounds.
Like that's so vague, like
again, even my dick was like,
"I want to be warm
with you too."
(audience laughter)
And even my heart was like,
"I would like to be
warm with her Kevin,
can we get this
done?" And I'm like,
"I'm sorry you can't be
warm with me, that's not...
I'm sorry, you can't." And
then she gets mad. She goes,
"You make me lonely!" Like that.
(audience laughter)
And I go, "I'm sorry, I'm
sorry I make you lonely,
but you still can't." And
she goes, "You're so smart."
And I go, "Yeah it's
ruined everything.
It's ruined my whole life."
(audience laughter)
"I wish I was less,
we'd be boning right now!"
And I'm like,
"Still you can't--"
And then she goes
to get on the bed,
and so I have to get
off the bed immediately
because that's some
real relationship shit
where you're like,
"Nothing happened!"
And she's like, "Were you on
the bed at the same time?"
And you're like,
"Yeah," and she's like,
"Well then we're over!"
It's some real white lady crap.
(audience laughter)
And so, she gets on the
bed, I get off the bed,
and then she keeps going, "I
want to be warm with you."
And she puts her perfect
caramel-colored butt in the air,
and I look at it,
and it's everything.
(audience laughter)
And so she starts kind
of crawling towards me,
like an 80s metal video.
(audience laughter)
And I'm like, "This is the
best! I'm in "Whitesnake.""
And she's crawling towards me,
and at that point
I go, "Mookie no!"
(audience laughter)
Like she was a dog, and
it felt real racist.
I'll be honest with you, it
didn't feel good to do or say,
and the sad thing was
it worked perfectly.
She just, you know.
And she gets up and she's like,
"Fine!"
Like that. But then, she
takes her underpants off,
and shows it to me.
She's like 'look at it.'
Basically she stood there like,
with it out, you know.
(audience laughter)
And it was like looking at
the Sun, but it didn't hurt.
(audience laughter)
And I mean it's like
you can finally just stare
at the Sun for a long time,
and you're like, "Look
the center of everything,
the reason there's anything."
(audience laughter)
And then again, I have to go,
"Mookie no, get out of here!"
(audience laughter)
And she leaves, she leaves,
I hear her go back upstairs.
And so what I do
as a guilty person,
I call my fiancee,
even though nothing happened,
I call her 'cause I'm like I
gotta tell her what happened
so I don't get in
trouble. So I call her.
She's...I start telling
her...she's having
a girls' night at our house,
so she puts me on speaker phone,
makes me tell the whole story,
and then her friends
just laugh at me.
(audience laughter)
And they're like,
"You're such a pussy.
Anyone else in the world
would've nailed this perfect,
'cause they looked her up.
I'm like, "This is
what she looks like."
They looked her
up, they're like,
"Anyone else would've nailed
her, you should've nailed her.
This is the hottest
woman you've ever."
But, this is the hottest
woman to ever offer me sex
in my entire life, and
the rest of my life.
Whoever, I'm single now, I'm
sorry to whoever I marry,
you lost already.
She was the best.
(audience laughter)
They laughed at me,
and it just felt like
having a winning lottery ticket
and then just burning it.
(audience laughter)
And you're like, "No no no,
I don't need that $20 million
on that lottery ticket
because I got $11
in checking at home,
and I'm good with that, you
can take your 20 million.
I'm burning it, I don't need it!
I don't care, I got $11
in checking at home."
And I'm not saying my
fiancee was worth $11,
but we're divorced now so
actually cost me thousands.
(laughing)
(audience laughter)
And the moral of the story is
this: What should I have done?
(audience member yells,
"Slept with her!")
(audience member, "Fucked
the shit out of her!"
(audience laughter)
Exactly sir.
There should've been
no sleeping ma'am.
(laughing)
Thank you so much, my
name is Kevin Christy.
(audience applause)
(techno rock music)